So,
and I also think,
and I think this is laid out very
thoroughly in the biblical stories as
well,
is that if there are enough people who
are admirable,
then things work and if there aren't and
things,
things are terrible,
you get wiped out.
You remember when Abraham is bargaining
with God with regards to Sodom and
Gomorrah,
he asks God to save the city.
If there's like 40 admirable people,
right?
Respectable,
let's say admirable,
right?
I don't want it,
I don't want to say good because good is
being corrupted in some sense.
By casual usage.
I mean admirable noble people,
right?
Yeah.
I think Abraham bargains God down to
like 10 if there's 10 of them in the
city,
the city won't be destroyed.
And that,
that's not very many in this city.
So there's an interesting idea there,
which is the there.
There doesn't have to be that many
people in a group who have their act
together,
but zero is the wrong number.
And if it's zero then then we're
seriously in trouble.
And I think that goes along with the
idea of the pareto principle in
economics too,
which is that it's a small minority of
people who do most of the productive
work in any given domain.
But so,
so a small number of,
of properly behaving people might have
enough of an impact to keep everything
moving.
And that might also,
they might actually be true,
but it can't fall below some crucial
level.
And I do think that we're in some danger
of allowing it to fall below some
crucial level because our society seems
to be at war in some ways against the
idea of the individual and individual
character per se.
And I think that's absolutely right.